What I want to do in this
video is talk a little bit more
about the concept
of an organelle.
And as you can see it
contains the word organ,
and that's because the
idea of an organelle
is related to the
idea of an organ.
If you're talking
about a human being,
if you're talking about
me, I have a liver.
A liver is an organ.
I have lungs.
I have a heart.
These are substructures of Sal.
Similarly, an organelle is
a substructure of the cell.
You could view it as almost
an organ of the cell.
And actually let me be a little
bit more particular there,
membrane-bound
structure of cell.
So for example,
let me draw a cell.
So that is my cell
right over here.
We're already familiar
with the idea of a nucleus.
A nucleus is a
membrane-bound structure,
so it is an organelle, nucleus.
We've talked about the
endoplasmic reticulum, which
is also a membrane-bound
structure,
so it is also an organelle.
We have talked about
the Golgi bodies.
Once again membrane-bound
structures, so it
is also an organelle.
So that's a Golgi
body right over there.
We have the endoplasmic
reticulum right over there.
And by this definition even
these small little vesicles,
these little membranes that
are carrying things around,
even these vesicles could be
considered to be organelles.
Vesicle.
And if you have
really large vesicles,
or a bunch of these
vesicles fused together,
you have these larger
membrane-bound structures
called vacuoles, which
could just be really viewed
as large vesicles or a bunch
of vesicles fused together.
Vacuoles.
All of these things, these are
all membrane-bound structures
inside the cell, and so these
are all considered organelles.
Now some people are a
little bit more particular.
When they really talk
about organelles they say,
OK, we could say maybe
membrane-bound structures,
but there are some
organelles that are not
only membrane-bound, but
they also have their own DNA.
For example, you
have mitochondria,
which I will do in pink, which
exist in most eukaryotes.
And this is really
the energy-producing,
I guess you could say, the
energy factory of the cell.
Let me draw it like this.
It has an inner and
an outer membrane,
so that right over
there is mitochondria.
It really takes sugars and
is able to take that sugar
chemical energy and turn it
into ATP, which I guess is still
a chemical energy but a more
useful, or a more readily-used
form of energy.
Mitochondria.
In plants you have plastids.
And the most famous, or at
least from our point of view
the most famous of
these are chloroplasts
where photosynthesis
takes place, where you're
taking light energy
and turning that
into chemical energy
in the form of sugars.
So this right over here,
this is a chloroplast.
Let me go into much
more detail with those
when we talk about
photosynthesis.
So that right over
there, a chloroplast,
which is a more particular
form of a plastid.
So I just drew a chloroplast.
But that's a more particular
form of a plastid.
It also has its own DNA.
And so mitochondria
and plastids generally
are fascinating
because it is believed,
because they have their own
DNA and they can replicate
themselves, that it's believed
that their ancestors were once
independent prokaryotes.
And at some point these
independent prokaryotes
started to get together and
into a membrane-bound structure
started to work
together in symbiosis.
And that kind of collaborative
of these prokaryotes working
together is believed to be
the predecessor of, say,
many modern cells that
contain these structures.
So it's a really
fascinating window
into how these things
actually might have formed.
But the big picture
here that I just
want to make sure we understand,
is that organelles, really,
it's generally viewed as any
membrane-bound structure,
anything as simple as a vesicle,
all the way to something that
has its own DNA, like
mitochondria or plastids.